et alors que la déclaration de l'ex
procureur du parquet national financier
eliane aux lettres le 10 juin dernier
avait à nouveau jeter le trou et la
suspicion dans cette affaire la justice
at-elle joué son rôle ou aurait dû
aurait peut-être dû ajourner le procès
est elle véritablement était
indépendante ou est elle instruit à
charge comme le dénonce en tout cas
aujourd'hui les républicains
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec à yves d'amécourt conseiller
régional et républicains de nouvelles
aquitaine à vos côtés yves d'amécourt
denis demonpion éditorialiste politique
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
heures direct avec nous sur rt france 5
ans de prison et on le rappelle dont
deux ferme dix ans d'inéligibilité
375000 euros damende en tout cas contre
françois fillon les républicains ce soir
yves d'amécourt dénonce une peine très
lourde est ce que c'est votre cas aussi
bien sûr c'est une peine très lourde qui
est sans commune mesure avec les faits
reprochés et puis derrière tout ça il ya
l'action d'un parc national financier
qui a été construit de toutes pièces en
fait pour chasser sur les terres de des
opposants de françois hollande on a
aujourd'hui les révélations des lianes
houlette qui nous explique elle a été
sous la pression de la procureure
générale pour accélérer la procédure et
chacun s'est bien rendu compte que
jamais le candidat françois fillon
n'aurait dû être mis en examen avant
l'élection présidentielle
tout ça est allé très vite il ya quinze
jours le les mêmes les mêmes magistrats
jugeaient une affaire de 1993 et
aujourd'hui on juge une affaire qui a
été très très vite et chacun chacun
aujourd'hui peut peut juger par lui même
que la justice n'est pas juste denis
demonpion l'eau au françois fillon on va
évidemment parler dans ce débat en
détail mais effectivement de la
suspicion une
décision qui s'est rendu peut-être dans
des conditions compliquées avec la
déclaration de l'ex procureur le 10 juin
alors écoutez il faut bien distinguer
deux choses déjà on peut pas que
déplorer que la justice soit à lévis
alors que généralement on a tendance à
déplorer sa lenteur et je pense que le
tribunal qui a statué aujourd'hui l'a
fait au vu des pièces qui avaient été
versés au dossier pour une part du
dossier n'est ce pas pour le reproche
fait à pénélope fillon dans le cadre de
la revue des deux mondes savait où elles
avaient été salariées par le président
de la revue marc ladreit de lacharrière
alors même qu'elle n'avait produit que
deux petites chroniques qui était un
petit peu suspecte quant à
l'authenticité
bon vous savez que dans ce dossier marc
ladreit de lacharrière lui-même a plaidé
coupable dans une procédure à part et
donc ça entraîné mathématiquement la
condamnation de pénélope fillon
donc sur ce cet aspect des choses
voilà il ya pas grand chose à en dire
ensuite pour ce qui est de l'emploi
fictif qui est reproché à nos clients
comme assistante parlementaire
on peut quand même rappeler aussi que
j'entendais les avocats là qui disait
qu'il verserait des pièces au dossier
rapport dont la justice aurait fait
abstraction etc
il faut quand même rappeler que dans une
déclaration publique journal britannique
elle avait déclaré qu' elle n'avait
jamais travaillé pour son mari et que
même elle n'avait jamais rencontré ses
collaborateurs donc il ya quand même une
petite suspicion pour le moins
quant à la peine qui a été prononcée non
elle n'est pas très surprenante
il faut se souvenir que dans un cas
précédent toujours d'ailleurs pour des
questions de profits typhon se souvient
qu alain juppé
alors même qu'il avait travaillé pour la
mairie de paris il était secrétaire
secrétaire général du rpr à l'époque
l'ancêtre des républicains il avait été
en première instance condamné lui aussi
à dix ans d'inéligibilité et à une très
lourde peine de prison
accompagné de sursis et ferme pour une
partie des classes il ya un appel
yves d'amécourt ans est vrai que des
affaires voilà d'attaché parlementaire
il y en a beaucoup à l'assemblée
nationale mediapart je vous donne
quelques chiffres on a relevé voilà 58
épouse rémunérés en 2014
28 fils 32 fitr députés au moins 20 %
nos élus aurait rémunéré un proche
ça veut dire qu'on voudrait on faire
selon vous un exemple de françois fillon
le moment était charnière le problème
c'est quand la justice n'est pas
équitable et donc effectivement au
moment de la sphère fillon mediapart
avait comptabilisé 7 en 1 32 ans qui
avait violemment terre de l'assemblée
nationale et du sénat et que c'était
illégal pour les parlementaires de du
parlement européen et donc la sphère
était légale bizarrement alors que ces
informations ont été rendues publiques
par mediapart
personne n'a été poursuivi je pense
d'ailleurs à bruno le maire qui est
notre actuel ministre de l'économie dont
l'épousé est artiste peintre et qui a
été branché pendant cinq ans à saint
service à l'assemblée nationale c'est
curieux alors que cette information est
publique
il ya eu deux ou trois articles dans la
presse que la justice ne s'intéresse que
aucun de françois fillon président
candidat à l'élection présidentielle et
pas aux autres dossiers de zagné
d'emplois fictifs
au même moment au moment où françois
fillon est inquiété au moment où il ya
les premières fuites dans le canard
enchaîné de quelque chose qui était
officiel puisque les salaires de
françois fillon était officielle est
déclarée et que les le couple font payer
ses impôts anne hidalgo qui était
poursuivi pour soupçon d'emplois fictifs
pour mm
je crois au ministère des solidarités
elle n'a pas été directement et a
bénéficié de la prescription
le 24 février avec l'entrée en vigueur
de la loi
fenech est donc l'accélération qui a été
mise en place à la demande du procureur
général
et on se demande aujourd'hui si ce
n'était pas aussi à la demande de jean
jacques urvoas et de françois hollande
pour que françois fillon soit bien mis
en examen avant le 27 février avant que
cette question ne rentre en vigueur
ce n'est pas équitable il y avait
plusieurs dossiers à ce moment là et que
ça le dossier de françois fillon a fait
l'objet d'une telle instance et d'une
telle cure et pour reprendre les termes
de 2 d'un juriste récemment denis
demonpion et sinon on peut se demander
si la justice peut être rendue
sereinement dans ces conditions monsieur
d'amécourt vient nous rappeler les
circonstances évidemment ou qui ont
coûté peut-être la présidentielle
françois fillon en tout cas il était
bien parti on rappelait que c'était un
candidat type totalisé 63 % des
intentions de vote à la présidentielle
en novembre 2016 là il ya eu cette
sortie de l'ex procureur le 10 juin
dans ces conditions est ce que les juges
dans le système actuel peuvent rendre un
verdict vraiment serein selon il ya deux
choses d'abord le parquet au cssa dette
pas de françois fillon
il est de fait sur les textes de loi
rattaché au ministère de la justice au
pouvoir quel qu'il soit hier comme
aujourd'hui il ya eu des discussions
souvient d'ailleurs du temps de jacques
chirac quand il celui ci était président
de la république pour savoir s'il
fallait couper le fameux cordon
ombilical entre le parti du pouvoir
politique dont il en a été décidé il a
été décidé que non puisque le pouvoir
politique voulait avoir un certain
regard sur la justice sur l'accusation
ce qui est le cas dans toutes les
procédures sensibles
mais il faut aussi ajouter que les juges
du siège qui eux statut endroit après
examen du dossier avoir écouté d'abord
les prévenus les avocats de la défense
des parties civiles s'il y en a
l'accusation par la voix du procureur
dit stature en toute indépendance et en
toute liberté
d'ailleurs ils sont nommés de manière un
peu distinctes et les juges du siège
comme on les appelle sont totalement
indépendants jusqu'à plus ample informé
je ne sache pas que une décision comme
ça et été prise sous pression de qui que
ce soit ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas
d'accord c'est votre avis également
oui vous avez entendu
l'audition sous serment du juge renaud
van ruymbeke par la commission denquête
de l'assemblée nationale qui est
présidée par un député de la france
insoumise renaud van ruymbeke a dit sous
serment
j'ai appris sur bfm tv la nomination des
trois juges sur la sphère fillon j'ai
dit à mon épouse
ça ça m'étonnerait bien si c'était le
cas je serais au courant et donc la
vérité c'est que ces juges ont été
choisis à dessein que ils ont été sous
le saisit le bonjour pour que ce soit
les juges de garde et on sait très bien
la réputation du juge tournaire dans la
justice et son indépendance
très honnêtement elle est peut-être
indépendante du pouvoir mais elle n'est
pas indépendante des idéologies et cette
semaine denis de montures le juge
tournaire qui a une réputation balade
d'hommes de goce est ce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut contester
dany des mendiants il se trouve que dans
le truc tu es sujet était d'abord
présidé par une président n'est ce pas
le juge d'instruction était
effectivement le juge tournaire qui a
qui étaient censés instruire à charge et
à décharge l'objet quand un juge
d'instruction
instruit à charge les avocats de la
défense sont là pour le rappeler à
l'ordre
et pour engager bataille et on c'est à
dire faire appel se tourner vers la cour
jusqu'à aller jusqu'à la cour de
cassation si besoin
donc il est difficile de faire le procès
d'une juridiction indépendante
au vu des déclarations d'un procureur
quand bien même il s'agit de l'ancien
procureur du parquet financier et d'un
juge d'instruction qui sans doute est
peut-être à cesser ses opinions
politiques
et je ne dis pas qu'il a toujours
d'ailleurs instruit en tout comment
dirais-je l'absence d'idéologie mais ça
c'est à démontrer en tout cas quand il
s'agit de juger une affaire comme ça a
été le cas dans cette affaire filion les
juges ne sont pas suspects et d'ailleurs
il suffit de reprendre la carrière et le
pedigree de chacun on ne peut pas les
suspects et de parti pris
ils vont appliquer la loi d'ailleurs
l'avocat de françois fillon
quentin à lévis a immédiatement dit
qu'il serait fait appel des dix ans
d'inéligibilité et évidemment de la
conduite de la de la prison avec sursis
et ferme qui a été prononcé et la cour
d'appel statuera alors si si
effectivement les avocats et françois
fillon lui même sont en mesure
d'apporter des pièces qui leur auraient
échappé jusque là bas très bien les
gants soit tenu compte
les briques dans ce premier procès a
déposé à peine je vous coupe c'est la
fin de ce débat merci denis demonpion
merci également à yves d'amécourt on
verra ce que va donner en tout cas
l'appel puisque y aura un deuxième
procès fillon merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté ce face à face ce soir
merci beaucoup